The joe rogan experience.
You can go to one 800 flowers.com from
your desktop or mobile device today.
Click on the radio microphone in the
upper right hand corner and enterJ r e Y.
Is that fine?
Someone else.
You could also get really
big stuffed animals.
Like look at this like getting ready,
getting your wife like,
Hey,
I just got your dorm is still looks like
a person that's bigger than a person.
That's stupid.
Pretty girl that I'm dating that if I
buy a five foot tossed stuffed animal it
for Valentine's should be pissed off in
my apartment
going on here.
I supposed to hug this when you leave.
What a weird fucking thing.
Some girls like it,
they love it.
Are you kidding me?
That's a smooth move.
You bring over a four foot teddy
bear that shits because it's unusual.
It's like a trick.
You know?
It's like,
it's really not like,
you know like if you had to like figure
out like what's the best size baseball
bat to play baseball.
Everybody's like,
well there'd be no more
limitations on baseball bats.
Well,
I'm going to pick up a fucking tree,
bro.
I'm going to fucking swing the tree,
but the tree is not the right size.
It's probably not one of those mini
baseball bats they give out at the stadium
and it's not a tree.
Somewhere in there is the right size.
If,
and I think that you would
find that out about bears too,
you'd get their big bear go,
listen,
this motherfucker's pissing me off.
This things everywhere.
I tripped over it in the middle of
the night when I'm going to pee.
This fucking bear is ridiculous.
I am the ultimate American consumers.
I have a fucking 80 foot tall bear,
handsome.
Henry's isn't name.
He's cute though,
but he's cool to cuddle with too.
Yeah.
Maybe it's a good pillow bed pillow thing.
When you're gone,
you're never home and
she could just spin it.
That could,
yeah.
They actually do sell things
for lonely bachelor's in Japan.
It's like a,
it was like a pillow,
like an arm.
I like reaches over it
like it's holding onto.
It's a very strange stuff.
I wonder if you could wash this.
Yeah.
Just get,
yeah,
don't,
don't get a pillow with
a fucking arm around it.
That's creepy.
If you want to sleep with a teddy bear,
you can pretend a teddy bears
its own individual thing.
Right?
Can you just with some weird fake arm,
and this is washable so you can
hump it all you want and wash it.
I'll fuck you going to wash them.
You're going to go
places where they clean sales.
Wait,
who are you going to bring
that fucking 20 foot tall bear?
It's washable.
Is fucking washing machine
is going to fit that bear?
Is there a human alive?
It's just a hose.
Put it in the driveway.
Yeah,
you got a hose that thing
down then it smells like mold.
Can't hose that down.
Maybe it's waterproof.
Maybe they're slick.
And since you're fixed,
smile this quicker.
No,
it's not fake.
She loves that bed.
Dude.
Don't be a dick.
I'm four feet tall.
What do you talk?
Why does it say I'm four feet tall?
Am I supposed to think that
the bears fucking talking to?
How about it's four feet tall?
I'm four feet tall.
The fight.
You're not fucking real man,
right?
That who's writing this shit for you?
Who's your ghost writer?
Bitch is another one.
Um,
anyway,
they're adorable.
One 800 flowers.com.
Yeah.